dusting off the finest pictures from his
body of work
David Bailey has photographed some of
the most iconic figures in living memory
more than 250 of his portraits are now
going on show at the National Portrait
Gallery he said what's my favorite room
is my favorite woman because it's sort
of my favorite woman ever he's a
Catherine my wife and all the pictures
in here more or less her very related to
like her sons and my sons and dog some
of the images in David Bailey's Stardust
exhibition are of people he won't
recognize but have been captured in that
unique and unforgettable style that has
immortalized so many actors musicians
and models I thought I'd make it kind of
entertaining interesting so I bring lots
of different techniques as well you know
like negative Polaroids or 11-inch
a 14 inch camera and negatives and so
make it sort of entertaining I think art
should be obscene in any way I want
people to come in and maybe learn
something but be entertained as well you
know I don't want it to be sad and I
could get me canned yeah Bailey has
never stopped working but he's probably
best known for capturing the swinging
60s even perhaps helping to define it he
kind of reminds me of one of those 1930s
film directors comic thing but all the
time you know he's looking and he's
looking for the picture and he has a
great eye he's a wonderful artist
well the exhibition is huge in fact it
takes up most of the ground floor of the
National Portrait Gallery there are 19
different sections each dedicated to a
different theme this one is fashion
icons and beauty as the late Alexander
McQueen and each and every one of the
pictures here has been chosen by David
Bailey himself it's taken him three
years to curate and reprint the pictures
he insists the exhibition is not a
retrospective but a collection of
favorites whatever you want to call it
it's a snapshot of the 20th and 21st
centuries through the eyes of perhaps
the most distinguished photographer
Britain has to boast Richard Suchet Sky
News at the National Portrait Gallery in
London